un appel du président carter pour que le
monde entier se mobilisent pour lutter
contre la faim dans le monde et enfin le
sauvetage de l'acropole voilà
l'actualité que je vous propose pour
cette édition de 13h de ce dimanche 18
juin 1978 qui verra les cérémonies
marquant commémorant l'appel du général
de gaulle se dérouler sous un ciel
nuageux certes pour l'instant il ne
pleut pas sur la région parisienne mais
il fait encore très frais hier par
exemple et il ne fait guère plus chaud
aujourd'hui le thermomètre n'a pas
dépassé 13 degrés on n'avait jamais vu
ça en france depuis que la météo tient
des statistiques c'est-à-dire depuis les
lendemains de la guerre de 70 cela bien
sûr n'empêchera pas les français
d'assister très nombreux aux différentes
cérémonies qui vont se dérouler
aujourd'hui tant à paris qu'en province
le chef de l'état participera à deux
rassemblements
le premier à 16h aura pour cadre la
porte d'orléans
il ya quelques mois la statue
symbolisant l'entrée du général leclerc
à paris en août 44 avait été détruite
par un attentat
cette statue a été réinstallé cette
semaine sur son socle et le président de
la république a décidé de présider la
cérémonie en hommage au maréchal leclerc
cérémonie qui a lieu cet après midi
ensuite à 19 heures monsieur giscard
d'estaing se rendra au mont valérien où
il présidera la traditionnelle cérémonie
qui tous les 18 juin se déroule dans cet
endroit près de paris quant à monsieur
michel debré il a choisi lui ce dimanche
pour prononcer un discours important
discours sur l'indépendance nationale
l'ancien premier ministre du général de
gaulle a choisi la date le 18 juin
il a aussi choisi soigneusement le lieu
il parlera h en cours à quelques
kilomètres seulement de colombey les
deux églises
nous vous en reparlerons ce soir sur le
plan politique peu de choses aujourd'hui
si ce n'est que dans quatre villes
les électeurs sont appelés aux urnes
quatre villes obernai flers aix en
provence et briançon il s'agit de
procéder à des élections municipales les
résultats du scrutin de 1977 ayant été
annulée par le conseil d'état
les spectateurs en tout cas auront
intérêt à se dépêcher s'ils ne veulent
pas manquer ce soir sur antenne 2 le
coup d'envoi du match pologne pérou qui
compte pour le deuxième tour de la coupe
du monde de football en argentine
c'est une journée très importante quatre
grands matches qui vont probablement
éclaircir très sérieusement la situation
dans le mondial
sur antenne 2 vous pourrez suivre à
18h35
très exactement pérou pologne puis peu
après minuit 00h05 00h10 le grand choc
argentine contre brésil l'allemagne et
la hollande de leur côté se retrouveront
à partir de 21h40 ainsi que l'italie et
l'autriche
mais la diffusion à partir de 18h30 donc
du match pérou pologne va bouleverser un
tout petit peu nos programmes de la
soirée
le journal de 20h ne commencera pas à 20
heures il débutera en réalité après le
coup de sifflet final
aux alentours de 20 heures 35 par de
nombreux pays cette coupe du monde vous
le savez suscite un intérêt énorme la
vie pratiquement s'arrête pendant les
retransmissions les états unis n'en sont
pas encore là mais de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et notre envoyé spécial
permanent jacques séguy s'en est bien
rendu compte le football devient un
sport majeur la dernière participation
les usa à une coupe du monde remonte à
l'année 1930 il était alors allé
jusqu'en demi finale battus 2 1 par
l'argentine déjà les américains referont
il bientôt partie de cette élite du
football à voir les jeunes de là bas et
bien cela semble maintenant probable
malgré les apparences cette scène se
passe à washington
chaque année
ici le football n'a pas le soccer et
pendant que les veilleurs celui qui sont
là-bas en argentine en train de se
discuter
le triple champion du monde et bien la
presse américaine
les journaux qui pour la première fois
annoncé la coupe du monde et radio
chaque jour avertissent le public pour
lui donner leurs deux rendez-vous de la
diffusion des matchs c'est une marée qui
tombe sur les états unis et qui n'a pas
fini de surprendre les états unis
feraient connaître les européens si
chaque dimanche c'est l'initiation au
football pour les petits amérique et le
responsable de cette affaire s'appelle
pelé et puis aussi beckenbauer
les deux grands absents de buenos aires
devenus les superstars du cosmos de new
york
et
pelé a pris sa retraite mais c'est grâce
à lui surtout que les américains ont
découvert la forme d'un ballon de
football un match ici est d'abord un
cérémonial avec la famille dans les
tribunes et la fanfare sur la pelouse
ici ce sont les diplomates qu'ils vont
jouer c'est à dire les clips de
washington pour l'heure il y à 24
équipes professionnelles aux états unis
avec un règlement aménagé pour le
spectacle il n'y a jamais par exemple de
match nul à la fin du grand con on tire
des penaltys pour départager les
adversaires les joueurs sont des
professionnels moins bien payés qu'en
europe
si l'on fait exception des salaires des
vedettes comme pelé et l'équipe
appartient à une compagnie de télévision
qui ne fait pas d'argent avec le
football mais qui compte en faire dans
l'avenir grâce au football et grâce aux
enfants si on en croit le directeur des
diplômes 12 parties par en tenue et
arbitres fourni dit le papa et ça nous
coûte que 16 dollars 80 francs
aujourd'hui 80 mille enfants jouent au
football à washington les descendants
des pionniers anglais surplus car pour
certains américains
le football c'est bien mais on ne se
sert pas de ses mains
autre innovation américaine
les équipes sont mixtes sans que la
coquetterie hyper de ses droits
il n'est pas impossible d'imaginer que
dans 20 ans les etats unis champions de
l'égalitarisme seront les premiers
champions du monde du football avec une
équipe composée de cinq femmes cinq
hommes et un gardien de but
ouais si on en croit le sunday times la
de nos confrères britanniques le conflit
du chabanais pas terminé plus d'un
millier d'aix gendarmes katangaise
aurait à nouveau franchi la frontière du
shaba et ils se seraient actuellement
regroupés autour de la ville de l'oua
chi selon notre confrère cette nouvelle
infiltration pourrait contraindre la
france et la belgique et une nouvelle
intervention militaire
quant à monsieur fidel castro il a
réaffirmé hier que cuba n'était lié ni
de près ni de loin aux affaires du zaïre
une déclaration diffusée dans tous les
états unis puisque fidel castro avait
accordé une interview aux trois plus
grandes chaînes de télévision
américaines
à genève les 13 membres de l'opep ont
commencé leurs travaux normalement une
décision sur une éventuelle hausse du
pétrole devrait être prise avant de
m'asseoir lundi les membres de l'opep
reste divisé le principal producteur de
pétrole l'arabie saoudite s'est en effet
déclaré toujours aussi hostile à une
hausse des prix avant la fin de l'année
le président jimmy carter lui se
préoccupe des problèmes de la faim dans
le monde le chef de l'état américain
aurait décidé de créer une commission
afin de coordonner la lutte des
organisations américaines et
internationales qui essaient de résoudre
ce problème de la malnutrition cette
commission aurait pour tâche aussi de
trouver un moyen d'accroître au minimum
de 300 % la production alimentaire des
pays en voie de développement et ce
avant la fin du siècle cela demandera un
effort considérable
un effort qui est souvent mal compris
dans les pays développés la fin il est
vrai a disparu de nos contrées tout au
moins la fin telle qu'on la connaît aux
à elle au bangladesh ou bien l'amérique
du sud pourtant ce fléau existait encore
en europe il n'ya pas si longtemps que
cela pour vous en persuader
je vous conseille de lire un livre du
norvégien knut hamsun un livre écrit en
1890 et que jean louis barrault évoque
pour nous sommes soon norvégien prix
nobel de littérature 1920 son
chef-d'oeuvre la fin paru en 1890 est
rigoureusement d'autobiographique ce que
la fin apporte de détresse de solitude
de douleur nous sommes sous ne l'a
ressentie jusqu'à la brûlure récits
terrifiants et sobre d'une époque pas
tellement éloigné de souffrance qui ne
cesse jamais
jean louis barrault en 1939 avait adopté
la fin pour le théâtre le phénomène que
la femme procurer le livre de knut
hamsun le montre bien
c'est que les souffrances de la fin vous
mettre dans un état d'hallucinations et
des formes toutes les perceptions qu'ont
peut recevoir du monde extérieur
si bien que cela me permettait de faire
des propositions
une sorte de manifeste théâtrale qui
pouvaient être utilisés justement des
choses déformées par exemple quand il
est dans un square et qu'il est torturé
par la fin il ya un monsieur qui vient
ce soir à côté qui lui parle et sème été
une occasion pour moi de faire une scène
de fatrasie car ils ne comprenaient rien
du tout à ce que disait cet homme tous
les maux que cet homme prononcées
étaient déformés au moment où il entrait
en lui dans le dal dans dans le corps de
tanguay 9 est organisée ce qu'est le
héros parce que dévoré par la fin ces
perceptions sont déformés son halluciné
si bien que je les mots n'avait plus
aucun sens d'ailleurs je m'étais amusé
comme c'était en 1938 39 et que c'était
après munich
quand il y avait une négation une
dénégation vernon pour dire non non non
non non tu disais dans la diada la dia
calavia on va jouer 27 et allah est
alors aussi c'était une chose tellement
proche de nous il suffit d'avoir un peu
d'imagination et pour s'apercevoir que
quand on est torturé par la faim ou par
la fatigue
la société vous êtes hostile et et tenez
par exemple
ça me rappelle quand j'ai fait mes
études je voulais faire les études du
jusqu'au bout enfin jusqu'au bout va
poursuivre mes études parce que j'aimais
ça mais comme je n'ai pas d'argent je
vendais des fleurs aux halles de 5
heures du matin à 11 heures du matin
puis je faisais mes études l'après midi
et le soir jusqu'à 10h30 je téléphonais
au client pour prendre les commandes
si bien qu à 4h30 du matin je me
retrouvais entre le pavillon des
gruyères et le pavillon des poissons
pour vendre mes fleurs sur le carreau
des halles résultat j'étais très fatigué
et j'avais tout le temps sommet et un
jour
je me suis endormi debout sur la plate
forme d'un autobus et je suis tombé les
gens m'ont ramasser je me suis réveillé
et qu'ai je vu autour de moi rien que
des regards hostiles au lieu d'être pris
de sympathie ou de dire tiens c'est un
garçon qui a faim moutier malades ou qui
est fatigué ou etc s'éteignent un petit
jaune hommes représentant la jeunesse
dépravée un petit sous l'eau un clip
ivres ou drogués et j'ai vu l'hostilité
de la société
et bien cette chose là je ne l'avais pas
oublier quand j'ai adapté afin de nous
en sommes à la courneuve les sapeurs
pompiers fouillent toujours les
décombres du salon de coiffure et du
café totalement détruit hier par une
explosion trois personnes ont été tuées
dans cette explosion est un jeune garçon
de 13 ans est toujours porté disparu il
semble bien qu'il ait été ensevelie sous
des tonnes et des tonnes de pierres et
de gravats
quant aux causes de cette explosion
elles ne sont pas encore exactement
connues mais tout laisse penser que
c'est le gaz qui en est le principal
responsable
l'acropole d'athènes est certainement
l'un des monuments les plus connus au
monde avec les pyramides d'égypte et le
temple d'angkor c'est en tout cas un
monument qui jusqu'à ces derniers temps
étaient chacun est visité par des
millions de personnes dans le temps et
les nuisances du monde moderne créé bien
des problèmes les archéologues et les
spécialistes d'aujourd'hui sont inquiets
il faut sauver l'acropole l'unesco a
offert une aide financière de la grèce a
refusé l'argent mais à demander l'aide
d'experts un comité de sauvegarde a été
créé l'opération sauvetage est
maintenant lancée elle va durer dix ans
au vème siècle avant notre ère périclès
et voulu faire d'athènes une cité modèle
pour l'ensemble des grecs sur ces
directives le grand sculpteur phidias
fait reconstruire l'acropole détruite
par les guerres médiques avec phidias
l'art classique grecque est à son apogée
l'acropole est un des joyaux du
patrimoine culturel mondial
après vingt-cinq siècles et bien des
vicissitudes ce qui reste aujourd'hui
des édifices de l'acropole une sorte de
squelette tout ronger blanchi exerce un
étrange pouvoir de fascination et
suscite des sentiments quasi religieux
dans le monde entier des gens modestes
sacrifient leurs économies pour aller
une fois rêver sur l'acropole
elle a même ses fidèles qui chaque année
reviennent l'admiré mais même la pierre
fut elle sublime et périssable le
chef-d'oeuvre de la civilisation grecque
antique est en danger vous voyez je suis
seul à me promener dans le parthénon
c'est absolument interdit au public
simplement parce que en 1977 il y a eu
deux millions et demi de visiteurs dans
le parthénon ce qui représente 5
millions de talons qui ont martelé ce
marbre et bien entendu ça n'était pas
fait pour ça à périclès n'avait pas
prévu une telle foule
alors pour l'instant c'est interdit ce
qui va être fait c'est qu'on va tracer
avec des blancs ce un chemin de poids au
centre du parthénon qui va permettre
dans quelques temps l'entrée des
visiteurs comme cela se faisait jadis
déjà un plancher protège une partie du
sol des propylées qui ouvre l'accès à
l'immense plate forme rocheuse
mais il ya des menaces plus grave les
poutres de faire placer dans tous les
monuments lors d'une restauration
générale en 1913 ont fini après 60 ans
parce oxydé il en résulte un gonflement
du métal qui fait éclater les blocs de
marbre
on ne peut incriminer personne ni même
parlé d'erreurs au début du siècle la
science ne disposait d'aucun autre moyen
pour cette consolidation qui tourne
aujourd'hui au désastre alors soulevé
archi traves des propylées
comme sous les plafonds de l'érechthéion
on place des étais avant de remplacer le
faire-part du titane inoxydable cette
extraordinaire travail durera six ans la
pollution atmosphérique enfin le soufre
contenu dans l'air se dépose sur la
pierre au contact de l'humidité il
devient un acide qui attaquent le marbre
et le rambo dès lors tous ceux qui
exercent une action mécanique quelconque
suffit à ronger les monuments la pluie
et même le vent deviennent redoutable il
a fallu abriter les cariatides sous un
auvent
le calcul des pertes leur surface
original et on doit prendre des mesures
pour les chauffer de cette destruction
donc on va les enlever on va les enlever
et les remplacer par des copies les
copies seront en ciment et vont rester
jusqu'à ce que la science moderne
trouvent des moyens pour consolider le
map les pierres qui ont se sont attaqués
par la part le progrès moderne
je veux dire la pollution atmosphérique
alors regardez les bien elles seront
bientôt comme les bibelots précieux sous
une vitrine
elle y rejoindront ce qui restait des
frontons du parthénon sculpté par
phidias ce que nous voyons ici est déjà
une copie
vous pensez qu'il faut combien d'années
pour sauver réellement l'acropole fou un
dizaine d'années en vain mais c'était
une question que ça n'arrête jamais on
est obligé de temps en temps de faire la
même opération pas tout à fait le même
est ce que maintenant on sait et le sait
la maladie on sait les moyens de nous
soigner un choix nier et je pense et que
avec des méthodes plus modernes que
chaque année nous avons des méthodes des
remèdes plus moderne
on va utiliser ses très chers et mid
mais je ne crois pas que ce sera
nécessaire d'enlever chaque fois les
carriers dit pour le monde eu lieu non
parce que le même problème ne se pose
pas pour tous les autres sites de la
grèce antique
oui mais pas dans la mesure que
j'avançais plus grandes difficultés à
l'acropole parce que l'acropole est
d'origine en génie et vasteville 2
millions elles sont des voitures sont le
bus et tous les vices passe par la
cotonne
la grèce va dépenser un milliard et demi
de drachmes 150 millions de francs lourd
pour sauver ses monuments antiques
elle a demandé l'aide technique des
experts internationaux la règle imposée
et qu'aucune restauration ne soient
irréversibles
il sera alors toujours possible dans
l'avenir d'utiliser les progrès de la
science
ainsi sera conserver aussi longtemps qu
il se pourra l'héritage laissé au monde
par la démocratie athénienne le berceau
de notre civilisation
voilà cette édition de 13 heures ce
dimanche 18 juin est maintenant
pratiquement terminé je vous rappelle
nos deux grands rendez vous de la soirée
à 18h35 tout d'abord du football avec le
match pérou pologne en coupe du monde
et puis à 20h35 notre journal de la
soirée pour le séparer je vous propose
de quitter quelques instants le sol de
notre planète il n'est pas question
d'aller très haut mais les adeptes du
deltaplane sont de plus en plus nombreux
et une école a été fondée elle permet
d'acquérir les rudiments de ce sport qui
est parfois dangereux un sport qui
permet d'oublier la pesanteur le bruit
et la fumée pendant quelques minutes à
ce soir bal après midi le deltaplane
c'est la concrétisation du vieux rêve
d'icare une forme de la liberté une
approche du danger quand une méchante
ravale devant veuves ou déséquilibrés
vous plaquer contre la falaise
c'est aussi un loisir proche de l'
aventure il se pratique partout les
ruptures de terrain permettent des
grands sauts que l'on serait tenté
d'appeler saut de la mort
non
il peut aussi se pratiquer en double
pour les besoins d'une acrobatique
interview télévisée au dessus david de
plus de 600 mètres le journaliste aime
vivre dangereusement certains du moins
mais ce jour là tout s'est bien passé un
véritable promenade de santé
car l'essentiel dans cet exercice est de
ne pas se brûler les yeux
m